[Music]
welcome back ladies and germs we're
doing another episode of am I the
[ __ ] yes people online poster lives
for us to judge you guys some jump in on
the comments we're gonna tell you where
we think and compassion or cut corner
fashion corner what is it today what's
the topic today it says am I the [ __ ]
for charging my sister twenty five
hundred dollars for one of my paintings
after her kid ruined it
compassion corner did she make the
painting huh two thousand five hundred
actually euros but we'll just say twenty
five hundred dollars and I'm gonna say a
pound it's a British [ __ ] conversions
I don't know $600 it depends on the year
whether it's whether our economy is
doing better thousand dollars okay I
want to hear this so this was another
little backstory light it's like in
preface but honestly she sounds like
kind of a [ __ ] so I'm gonna read this
person says backstory I'm 26 and a
fairly successful artist my sister Lucy
and her nine-year-old child Ethan were
at my house during a late New Year
celebration I had a sign posted on my
art studio saying do not enter and
specifically made it clear to guess that
nobody was to enter that room I'd also
like to note that all of my guests were
asked to leave their kids as this was
for adults but Lucy couldn't do that
because she couldn't find a sitter
anyway it's almost like dude I was so
busy come on so it says well she's
biased I'd be biased telling the story
to [ __ ] up my opinion it was my house
and I said no kids and then my sister
brought their kid I'd be pissed yes I
would leave the kid outside yeah it's
cold and it's dark you can leave your
kid in the car yeah sign that says no
kids allowed they're gonna overheat it's
the winner right exactly you could do it
legally 20 years later in therapy and
they left me in the car no kids night
sorry okay so it's 10 p.m. and I here so
this is the night of the party it's 10
p.m. and I hear a loud crash from my
studio I run up and see paint all over
my recent work that so far had taken 15
hours to do
Ethan was sat there laughing rubbing
paint into my work it's now
unsalvageable and i have to restart the
work as it was a specific request from a
client which also puts me behind the
rest of my work now I immediately asked
Ethan and Lucy to leave and the next day
I sent her a bill for the work 2,500
pounds which is lower than what I would
have gotten for the work anyways she's
absolutely screaming about it my whole
family is divided my mom hates me my dad
completely agrees with me and surprised
my dad is an artist my mom is more smart
smart my sister I will admittedly say I
don't enjoy kids either company but I've
always been a great aunty presents and
Christmas gifts from every vacation
everything he's wanted am I the [ __ ]
for charging my no no I hate what family
thinks that what you do for work is just
play is that what her sister said she's
pissed so apparently the mom and the
sister are like what the [ __ ] yeah
they're not artists they don't get that
big view you can just be do it all I
think out of that reason
yeah but then originally if they were
super sorry about it or whatever I
wouldn't have charged them that's you
though this person's livelihood is
commission-based
and she was getting commissioned by yeah
but money and family I never charge
family that's just my rage you lose the
client or did she just have to start
over has to start over but it put her
behind on all the other work can't you
just trace anyone maybe she can sell
that's out the messed up painting well I
don't think it's just only the painting
and itself is also the materials that
have been wasting the time yeah because
like if pain is everywhere and then the
brushes are ruined
that should cost a lot of money so like
you need a like fine yes like if your
dog [ __ ] on a carpet and ruined it it's
like they didn't even offer to fix it or
pay it or anything right I think it's
that principle yeah and I but III don't
know like so for example if this
happened to me I knew their financial
situation they were broke and they're
really [ __ ] sorry about it I'll be
like yeah but in my situation yeah yeah
but if I knew that they had money and
they're reacting in a way where it's
like what's the big [ __ ] deal that
[ __ ] I'm charging you everything [ __ ]
you
yeah they're like she's like hey pay
this and then the sisters screaming at
her like it's ridiculous like instead of
being like hey I'm sorry like it'd be
[ __ ] up but we can't afford this much
it doesn't sound like the sisters even
has any even has any compassion I won't
say there's also attacked about doing
this to where it's like instead of just
sending a bill like that yeah it's like
yo explaining my situation this takes a
lot of time this takes a lot of energy
money etc this damaged my financial
situation I need like this and you know
I mean even a little more tactful about
it there's always some good in the fact
that the person that you know the kid
that [ __ ] it up
that family didn't even offer first I
think that's [ __ ] yeah they're not
apologizing it doesn't sound like the
kid was made to apologize or any they
immediately went into an excuse like oh
yeah my kid [ __ ] kids are gonna be
kids if some1 say that I will grab their
[ __ ] kid [ __ ] like a football
don't [ __ ] grab him and I'll be like
you need to pay for this [ __ ] right now
yeah you're not leaving this house and
then they send you a medical bill I'm
like dude those paints are toxic man you
don't want to deal with that an
especially expensive ones too well not
you I think that this person is missing
out on a lot of money because when kids
paint [ __ ] people go [ __ ] crazy in
our role now this you've made this
reddit post and it blew up sell that
[ __ ] well you know there's a story
behind the painting my thing though is
too is that I'm kind of like I kind of
like see your point of view because like
I really wouldn't really want to like
charge family and I see the point of
like what if they have money I think if
they have money then twenty five hundred
might have just been a drop in the
bucket and it wouldn't have been but
both both attacked where it's like hey
this really hurt my business like
explaining it in their language they
don't understand that art is business
for this person apparently so explaining
it in like words that they understand
like you know imagine someone ruined
your you know desk job work or whatever
for a week and now there's actually stop
dating a girl because she didn't take
YouTube seriously
yeah very beginning I'm like oh we got
to go make some skits and stuff and
she's like they're just videos and as
soon as I heard that I'm like
this is nothing or a lot of people think
that just cuz you're home all day that
you're like chillin and you're having a
blast like yeah instead of like you're
editing videos you're planning out video
people you're like or you don't get out
how about you don't get a [ __ ]
weekend because you're you're working on
[ __ ] yeah networking [ __ ] it's a part of
the job like I've had to go to dinners
it I don't wanna [ __ ] go to people
that are like oh you're having fun all
the time just talking to people and
eating food or your life so hard you get
dinners paid for like streaming on
Twitch all the time I would get like oh
you're just sitting there playing video
will that I agree with that one's pretty
hard to defend you know I mean it's just
hard to defend
imagine a guy coming out of a coal mine
and you're going you're like listen it's
just it's the same kind of thing you
compare anything to a guy coming out of
a coal mine I know okay real quick if
not for this context 2 of you you
telling me that the artist had already
had this commission from a client I
think me and Joe probably this entire
video have been making fun of this guy
for thinking his paintings worked well
because you said that because there's no
value behind it right he could put any
he's like this is a million dollar
painting canvas yeah woman but yeah
where that 2500 comes from because
personally well I think I probably would
have done was a not sent an invoice to
my see yeah
that's a [ __ ] move they do not have a
good relationship to begin with like you
don't talk about things properly it
sounds like hey no kids hey I brought my
kid [ __ ] you and then my kid [ __ ] up
your painting it's like whoa what is
this [ __ ] [ __ ] you I think where there
might be a little sibling rivalry could
be but I am that sounds like some [ __ ] I
would have charged for the supplies the
canvas assuming this is like a big
painting that would be really expensive
but we're not twenty-five hundred
dollars and that thousands really comes
from is the skill that this person has
acquired over the years as an artist and
that is her decision to raise or lower
that price
well fifteen hours of work she's
probably like you know fifteen hours it
was worth twenty five hundred dollars
plus the all the supplies she did
our 250 yeah not much for that yeah for
the what she got commissioned to do
right but that's that's the skill thing
and that's where you have the power to
have a little compassion to a family
member like even if you told her not to
bring the [ __ ] kid or not like and
say like okay just pay me for the
supplies you [ __ ] [ __ ] also you can go
to a goodwill buy a painting and then
paint on top of that in part be way
ahead of time that probably refurbished
painting yeah there's a lot of that out
there that's that's cute as [ __ ] yeah
people do that they look like modern
graffiti art over old antique paintings
or they put like a little Mario Brothers
in the old-looking Brothers Luigi the
white chocolate G is pronounced
correctly Mario and Luigi you said
exactly right I've seen a lot of those
or you they put duck hunt em in like an
old renaissance looking painting did she
ever break down like what you all
thought she was charging by the hour
she should have posted a picture of her
painting - I think this is [ __ ]
sibling rivalry and this woman hates
kids she mentioned in in like these
little paragraphs that she hated
children three times no kids allowed
your sister brought a kid to spite her
yeah like she just made all these little
jabs that were like very anti kid and
then at the very end she says I will
admittedly say I don't enjoy kids and
we're like [ __ ] we know we got it
understand people that don't like kids
I think I don't like kids if they're not
my kids that's not true we love our
nieces an if I know what I'm trying to
double them the way she talked about the
kids I think for me like I'm weary of
kiss just because I don't really know
anything about them so because like I
don't trust you rate of a cape I don't
[ __ ] get you so I'm not gonna be me
to me it's like a whole different life
force to me it's just like like they're
the Ewoks and [ __ ] of course about kids
like it's just too loud like in a
high-pitched loudness it's
too loud don't be it's funny because la
kids cannot make me pissed or they could
never do wrong yeah I had a kid I was
tutoring at this projects and he flipped
me off in my face and he said [ __ ] you
and he ran away I was like you [ __ ]
idiot you know I love kids just the
times that they scream is that yeah but
think about this parenting has to be so
[ __ ] sick in 2020 when you can put on
noise-canceling headphones
so imagine joe sitting there and this
kid's like know that deal yeah I'm just
like we had a great invention idea so
you know how babies crying because
everyone off a catapult bit nut what
that's good to know that's really good
so we a pacifier or like some sort of
device that goes over the mouth that
makes the cry sound like music yeah but
then we found out from our doctor that
that's a really bad idea because
apparently what turn into something else
or would you rather just mute it out you
could it's a function you could choose
you know you can make it sound like an
alien so it's like right used I have
like nine nephews and nieces right so I
kept hearing cries all the time so now
when I hear it on an airplane like it
used to piss me off but now I'm just
like oh that's kind of familiar not me
man I'm the baby of the family came
after me and I didn't have to take care
of any kids so I think that's why I like
when I see a kid like I'm more nervous
around them because I don't know what to
do don't know what to do yeah and you
like if they're freaking out I'm
freaking out because I'm like what do
you know they're just as pretty as
you're afraid of
[Music]
[Music]